قد يلاحظ الكثيرون ان بعض الاماكن تحديدا
قد تثير مشاعر الغضب والانزعاج لديها فيما
تشعرك اماكن اخرى بالهدوء الراحه الامر
ربما يتعلق بسيكولوجيه الالوان وهي تلك
تاثيرات التي تظهرها الالوان المختلفه على
نفسيه الفرد وطباعه وبات يعرف استخدام
سايكولوجيه الالوان في التسويق والاعلام
بشكل كبير لقوه تاثيرها على الاشخاص
بالفعل فقد اثبتت العديد من الدراسات
النفسيه ان الالوان لها العديد من
التاثيرات القويه على العواطف والحاله
النفسيه وفي الحضارات القديمه استخدمت
الالوان كادويه وعلاجات مثل الحضاره
الفرعونيه والهنديه القديمه والحضاره
الاغريقيه اما حديثا تطور الامر لتظهر بعض
المراكز التي تستخدم الالوان كعلاج
[موسيقى]
على نفسيه الشخص هل بالفعل لها تاثير هل
هو عالم ام اجتهاد احنا كل واحد في حواليه
مجال كهرباء مغناطيسي والالوان
فاذا كان اللون الزياده او في نقصان تعمل
عدم توازن الجسم بتحسي اذا دخلت على غرفه
معتمه بعد فتره بدك تطلعي غرفه كثير برضه
بيضه برضه فلازم يكون في توازن بالالوان
ونشوفها طيب لما انا من محبي اللون الاسود
يعني في كل مناسبه صغيره وكبيره دائما
لابسه اسود
طيب خلينا نطب هاي الفكره
الاسود الاسود
انا اشهد الاثنين فمود وقوه
بيجي الواحد لابس اسود بتحسي هيك بيعمل لك
كانه ابعدي عني شوي اعطيني سبيس فكثير
بنصح فيه في مقابلات العمل اذا بدك الادنى
لوظائف اداريه عاليه احسن لون مقابلات بس
للمناصب الاداريه العاليه مثلا اذا انت
رايحه لوظيفه مثلا استقبال او مع الناس لا
تعطي مسج مش ال تعطي رساله مش اللى بدك
توصليها فهي غموض وتحمل مسؤوليه وهذا
اللون هذا اللون كله هذا اللون كان نادر
جدا واكتشفه الملوك بالزمنات وكان بس
محصور عليهم بعدين اعطونا الشعب غموض وسحر
بتلاقي مثلا محلات ال همم
بيستخدموه محلات
ملكه بريطانيا
كانوا يسمعوه هناك الوان اخرى لها تاثير
مباشره الازرق الازرق السما البحر راحه
النفس بتشوف اللي بتطلع على البحر قديش
بترتاحي بيعطي الثقه بيعطي اللي لابسه انه
انا بشتغل بطريقه من العمل ما بخاف من
اتخذ القرار بل بالعكس بناقش حوالي طيب
الاحمر والاصفر والاحمر والاصفر الاحمر
بعلامه التوقف التوقف عن المرور خطر بيعمل
هيك صدمه للجهاز العصبي بتلاحظ انه
بيستخدموه مثلا بالتنزيلات
بالاكلات السريعه حتى توقف وتطلع عليه
بنصح بالاصفر بس للوظائف الابداعيه فيها
طاقه بيدل على اني جاريه وانا موجود
[موسيقى]